[music]
I want women like them too. I know
many women who don't stay silent. Tell them. They
need to be punished. Tayfovskyi
is currently in a
very difficult situation because
it is complicated by the fact that not all victims
are ready to speak. The
whole society knows about numerous
rapes
. Journalists know about it, but the victims do.
they are afraid not to speak, there is also a stigma in
society and there are fears that the
Russians may return, therefore it is very
difficult for our law enforcement agencies to
work with these cases, and currently, according to the
information of the Prosecutor General,
100 more than 100 cases of
sexual violence are being investigated,
of which the statistics are very scary, the youngest
victims are four years older  85 it is terrifying,
but the fact is that this is a small
number of those crimes that have been
committed, in fact
, the task of
our society now is to
give the opportunity to speak from the heart, and they
will speak only when they
feel
psychological comfort, and this is
very difficult
to achieve.  I am sure of this and precisely because of that  about
all these cases, most of which we know about, these
are not hidden acts of crime, which
the Russians themselves sometimes tell on the
phone of their loved ones, and these phone
stories are intercepted
precisely because of the
repetition of such cases, the
brutality of them suggests and the lack
of confidence that this is a
deliberate weapon against Ukrainians
without
permission  without the
approval of the military leadership, such a
number of sexual crimes could not have
been committed by any army in the world. Therefore, we
insist that this is their deliberate
weapon, sexual violence is a weapon in
this war,
everyone who is associated with
work in Ukraine with sexual
violence During this war, they  we
are sure that this number is a little
more than 100, this is just,
as we said, a drop in the ocean, but
the fact is that all crimes must be
proven, and now
Ukraine is not working to bring its
legislation to the
standards that correspond to, for example, the
Istanbul Convention,
thanks to these
changes, the victim  will feel more
protected, we will have other approaches  to the
investigation of cases related to
sexual violence, non-
discriminatory protection of the individual who
will testify, and we hope
that this series of changes will also give impetus
to people to start talking,
but I am sure that the majority, the
majority of what we
do not know yet, we will find out  only after the
release
[music] the
situation is really terrifying because
when the Russians take these children, the
Ukrainian social services know nothing more about
them and it is really a crime
because the parents are responsible for the child while it is young,
if
it has them, if there are no parents, if
she is somehow deprived of
parental care
, the state is responsible for her, and this is the state
that was responsible for these children.
Now we do not know anything about what
is happening to them,
instead, the
Russians are constantly informing like this.
adopted and they give them up
for adoption from  new, after all, without
approval from
their homeland, nothing more can be
said about it, it’s just kintnapping
and the use of children as an informational weapon,
they also take advantage of the fact that children cannot answer yet, they
cannot
protest, they do not understand something, and they
use them as such.
This is very cynical,
it is difficult for me to pick up  words are
in the hand of action, they changed their
legislation and
simplified the adoption procedure for
children from Ukraine. It is also
shameful, unfortunately, the worst thing is that we
cannot get any information about
where these children are, what conditions they are in, who among them is
adopted
, etc. This unknown is really horrifying to
France
cases of the world,
I don't think there is such information. It
seems
to me that the situation with children is generally very difficult,
because they themselves are unlikely to
be able to testify. We can now say that
several hundred children have already been
killed during this war, and this is a terrible
statistic, and
how is it written correctly
here?  you can't match and in fact
they use the whole range of
possible tools  battles for intimidation and
killing of Ukrainians here too. We
hope for the help of the entire free
world. Today I will appeal to the
parliament
so that Great Britain becomes the leader in the
creation of an
international tribunal, because really
simply ending the war
is the first stage. The second stage is to find and
punish those who committed crimes.
orders and this is really a matter of justice
We will never be able to
feel safe until we feel
justice akesh phone
Ukraine
It is really a struggle but the
state will stand by the victims in this case the
state of Ukraine has
such intentions and
our law enforcement agencies of our
Prosecutor General's Office
clearly see this  my goals, that's why I
'm sure that when the victims
fight for justice,
not when they are supported by the state and
civil society, there are more chances
that
we can all achieve justice together,
so I really hope that
we will succeed.
I will answer honestly. I don't want to talk to him
directly. I don't want to ever be  in
this
taco situation
It seems to me that there is not one Putin there, there is a
collective Putin, and
in this case the entire team should be
punished.
To be honest, I have great doubts
that I can
comment on this situation, this is too
political a field and I try
not to go so deeply into it. I think that
this
the statement of the President of Ukraine
was necessary at the moment when he
expressed it and it is relevant even now, whether
it will change or whether his position will change,
we do not know now, but
I think you can only ask
the President of Ukraine about it.
It seems to me that
every mother has the same emotions now  and wives in Ukraine, and this and
anger also because our life is
trying to break all our plans, all
our hopes, everything that we longed for, everything
that we wanted for our children is now either
broken completely or is on pause
because now is the time to dream And it
can really be described  my emotions are anger
because I don't understand how one or even a
few people in the world
can have the audacity to decide for me
how I should live H  ow people in Ukraine We of
counce washing
[music]
We hope now that
we will still partially
recover gradually, we will have hope that
there will be more of these parts with electricity in Ukraine
Now I can describe how
the days and nights pass, for example, people who
live in Kyiv  in the Kyiv region,
power outages occur all the time,
you must have time to do the
necessary
household things even at these hours when there is
electricity, and when there is no electricity,
there is also no communication. That is, you cannot work online
or go
to zoom meetings, which we are already used to,
sometimes you cannot  to have water or
heating because this is also a part
of the energy infrastructure that was
damaged. We are already used to candles.
Everyone has candles. Everyone has flashlights. People
understand the
most powerful diesel generators.
Who has the opportunity to
buy such things?
Some huge household batteries that
people already have everywhere.
Ukrainians are resourceful, I saw yesterday a
funny video of a girl drying in  sat in the
car
with
this heater turned on at full blast and because
there was no light in her house and people even
joke about it and make funny
tik-toks. But
it is really very
strange that in the 21st century in a developed
metropolis like Yakov, people should
find an opportunity to
recharge their phone
Currently, points of inviolability are being established all over the country,
these are either tents
or some kind of
public buildings are used where people can come there for
warmth, they can recharge their
gadgets, get hot tea, coffee or
some snacks to
rest
, etc. and such points should be everywhere. The
first to make
such points was the
Emergency  We are really conducting them, they did
it at an unprofessional level, unfortunately, not all
representatives of the local government immediately took a
responsible approach to this
task, and in Ukraine
, the process of decentralization has been going on for a long time.
That is, all economic
tasks in the regions should be performed
by the local government, but
I already know  there are many examples that this
situation is changing. Therefore  oh, here
society really needs such points and
they need to be really high-quality,
you can get
help there and have them everywhere. I really
hope that this week the situation
will change.
adults and they
try more courageously than
adults Volodymyr and I try to behave in such a way
that they are calm for us and
are sure that everything is fine
with us.
as
we speak in Kyiv, there is an air alarm
and at this very moment my child is being taken
from school and returned home and now I am
worried about whether he will be able to
get home safely,
we are all the same.
it's difficult, children don't
ask every day when it ends
and we don't know what to answer them until
we
move on  another topic because to honestly
answer that I don't know is to take away the
child's hope that's why we change the topic
[music]
fiya
I really hope that although my constant
presence somehow gives them
peace of mind father they see
very rarely
not long episodes and enjoy
them
as much as they can but  there really aren't
enough
moments like this When we can stop
counting time and just be together And not
look at the clock When we
when we have to go in different directions
Yuriy Life is a
complex question so complex Yesterday
I
watched from the window of the car
how charming
London is already decorated And  there really is such a
nostalgia for holidays that we
won't have
in Ukraine this year, now
we're just even arguing about whether it's appropriate,
for example, to
install a Christmas tree in Kyiv, even
energy-saving, one that won't
take a lot of electricity.
in Ukraine as such
, unfortunately, it will not be, somehow we will
still
warm one and the same  each
other, but
it will not be a magnificent holiday, so I would like to
say to the British people, I want them to
enjoy this holiday,
but remember that it is not forever, unfortunately,
it is not
an absolute unchangeable thing. We also
celebrated New Year, Christmas last year, and were
happy
at that moment  when you hug your
family, look at the New Year tree at the
garlands
[music] make a
wish
I would like them to wish us all in
this wish Peace It seems to me that every
child this year in Ukraine wants
Victory and peace and will
ask St. Nicholas for this Let's
ask together  with us. If this is not
a naive
wish. And in general, if we are talking about
physical aid to Ukrainians, they need to
survive the winter, and my foundation,
among other things, is raising funds and finances to
purchase for Ukrainians something that can
warm generators, heaters, blankets,
this is our wish, physical,
about our wishes  What in my heart I already said
iPhone
is our main goal
Ukraine
this online and
[music]